les féminines de vélizy peuvent exulter
les sportifs viennent de remporter leur
cinquième victoire de la saison en six
matches disputés leurs victimes du jour
châteaudun lévisienne s'impose dans leur
gymnase 3 sets à 0 le score 25 à 20 25
11 et 25 à 8
balade de santé non le premier sac
n'était pas la réalité sociale justement
c'est en psycho logiquement se mettre
dedans et après par la suite
effectivement ça c'est rodez on a été
plus propre dans le fond de jeu s'est
dit satisfait par rapport à la causerie
d'avant match
justement on a essayé d'appuyer sur le
fait de jouer ensemble se faire plaisir
et de tenir le jeu qu'on a par la tenue
sur les derniers matches dans la
régularité donc bonne réaction des
filles avec cette victoire les
bélizienne conserve la première place du
championnat de nationale 3 devant
argenteuil et le promu ne s'enflamme pas
donc là cette année c'est une année de
plaisir maintenant les filles commencent
à chercher justement à faire des
résultats
mais les objectifs du club
c'est demain c'est de se maintenir moi
c'est d'essayer de fallout a beau et
puis ça va et puis ici sont gourmandes
donc on va voir si pour continuer à
rêver d'une montée en nationale 2 vélizy
devra s'imposer le 17 novembre prochain
face à son dauphin au classement
argenteuil
une victoire et les yvelinoises pourrait
déjà une sérieuse option sur la première
place
[Applaudissements]